hey everyone and welcome to the things
if you love Riverdale as much as we do
you probably can't get enough of its
amazing casts we've scoured the internet
to find some of the show's funniest
bloopers and sweetest behind-the-scenes
moments you won't believe just how close
the Riverdale actors are in real life if
there's one thing Riverdale fans have
noticed its how gorgeous the cast is
just look at this side-by-side shot it
speaks for itself
who knew that KJ who plays Archie
Andrews was the most fashionable one of
the bunch the gang has been through so
much together and after three years of
filming they've become huge parts of
each other's lives in fact some of them
have even formed long-lasting romantic
bonds take Lily Reinhart and Cole
Sprouse for example the actors fell in
love while on set much like their
character did in the series Riverdale
fans can't get enough of bug-head
there's such a hilarious couple just
look at them goofing around in this
behind-the-scenes moment
Lilly and Cole are clearly on the same
wavelength but they aren't the only
couple who caught each other's attention
while on the set of Riverdale actors
Charles Melton and Camilla Mendes who
play Reggie and Veronica respectively
also found love while shooting the
series there is such an adorable couple
sorry barchi fans but Reggie's got our
vote KJ doesn't seem to mind though
because he and Charles have their own
bromance to look forward to
despite butting heads on the show KJ and
Charles are super close pals in real
life they do everything together and
that includes coordinating their outfits
on Halloween KJ Charles and drew ray
Tanner who plays things dressed up as
Josie and the Pussycats for Halloween
they totally nailed their outfits but
they aren't the only ones who took the
world by surprise with their gender
defying Halloween costumes because let's
just say that Camilla and Lily took
things up a notch or two as well Lilly
Reinhart chose to dress up as Napoleon
Dynamite while Camilla Mendes dressed up
as his partner in crime Pedro
so did the girls pull off this look
whose group Halloween costumes did you
like best
Archie Charles Andrews or lily and
Camilla's let us know in the comments
section but first let's enjoy a
behind-the-scenes moment of Lily
channeling Napoleon's epic dance moves
now that was something it's easy to see
that the entire Riverdale cast has a
special sense of humor some would even
say there are adorkable but when it
comes to posting hilarious pictures Cole
Sprouse comes out on top
Cole posted a jaw-dropping Instagram
picture that had fans grinning from ear
to ear fans were in disbelief over
Ronald's photoshop skills especially
since he swapped out Camilla's face for
Cole's instead of Archie's Riverdale is
such a serious TV series that it's easy
to forget these actors share plenty of
laughs behind the camera the Riverdale
cast has quickly become a family and
Families love to joke around pick on
each other and celebrate important
moments in each other's lives so an
actor Jordan Connor who's known for
playing sweet pea got engaged to his
longtime girlfriend Jen Jarrah Mitchell
the Riverdale cast just had to celebrate
you're engaged
actress Madeleine pets who plays Sheryl
blossom posted this sweet moment on
snapchat we can see actors Vanessa
Morgan and Skeet Ulrich who played Tony
topaz and FJ Jones respectively hanging
out in the background it's not every day
that the gang gets to celebrate an
engagement but birthdays are plentiful
this time it was Madeline's turned to be
in the front of the camera the cast
circled around Madeline to sing her
happy birthday she's wearing a tiny
little crown and looked super happy to
be celebrating her Riverdale family KJ
was filming this tender moment and he
ended the video by goofing around with
the girl next door Betty Cooper have you
ever wondered what the Southside
Serpent's do when no one's watching well
so have we so we did a little digging
and found out that serpents like Tony
and fangs like to rock out with their
snapchat filters out behind the scenes
in real life Anessa Morgan and drew ray
Tanner have very different styles so
whenever they throw on their leather
jackets they let their inner rockers
come out now you would think that the ex
serpent leader fp' Jones would be
rocking out alongside them but actor
Skeet Ulrich seems to prefer the
classics over death metal in this
behind-the-scenes moment we see skeet
driving Charles Melton and dylan sprouse
to an unknown destination
Charles is chewing a piece of gum in the
backseat tricking skeet into thinking
that he's singing along to the music but
wait what is still in Sprouse doing with
the Riverdale cast what happened to Cole
it looks like Effie Jones inherently
adopted his on-screen son's twin brother
it feels like only yesterday that Disney
Channel stars cole and dylan sprouse
were causing mischief on the beloved TV
series The Suite Life of Zack and Cody
the Sprouse twins were inseparable for
most of their lives so many Riverdale
fans were shocked when Cole was cast as
Jughead Jones leaving Dillon to his own
devices so we're not too surprised to
find out that Dillon comes to hang out
with the Riverdale cast whenever the
opportunity arises seeing the Sprouse
twins side-by-side might have been what
caused Lilly Reinhardt and Camilla
Mendes to burst into song behind the
scenes
[Music]
in this video we see Lily and Camilla
laying down next to each other while
belting out the sweet life theme song
yep sounds like they pretty much nailed
it
we bet Lily never once thought she'd end
up dating Cody Martin while binge
watching the hilarious Disney Channel
series The CW's Riverdale is a huge
success
so it comes as no surprise that the cast
is constantly traveling to new
destinations to film interviews or
attend events the Riverdale cast knows a
thing or two about photoshoots as well
and they always put their best faces on
every single character and actor brings
something new to the table still it's
hard to take our eyes off the show's
leading ladies and they know it too
Camila Mendez posted this adorable
picture of Lily Madeline and herself
attending a glamorous event and soon
after she uploaded this scandalous video
to her Instagram page these leading
ladies are on fire and their outfits are
drop-dead gorgeous
which leading lady is your favorite
Veronica Betty Sheryl or Josie the
Riverdale cast spends a lot of time at
pops chocolate shop so we're not
surprised that they've become super
chummy with the one and only pop Tate
who is portrayed by actor Alvin Sanders
here's an adorable behind-the-scenes
selfie which was captured by cole
sprouse and posted by camilla mendes pop
Tate has made the gang hundreds of
Milkshakes over the years which is
probably why Jimmy Fallon wanted to
share a milkshake with the cast while on
the set of The Tonight Show Starring
Jimmy Fallon the leading actors joined
forces to guzzle down a chocolate
milkshake and Jimmy Fallon totally
snagged jugheads classic hat if there's
one thing Riverdale fans look forward to
every year it's Comic Con and the same
can be said about the cast they love to
meet their fans which is why they can't
wait to attend this yearly event the
show's leading actors played a game of
truth or dare at the 2018 Comic Con
event which was hosted by E news they
took turns asking each other questions
or giving each other dares and the
outcome was hilarious
in this clip we see KJ mocking his
on-screen rival Hyrum Lodge who is
played by actor Mark Consuelos mark
doesn't seem to mind the shade though
but the look on Ashleigh Murray's face
says it all by the look of things mark
can be a little uptight from time to
time but it's safe to say that most of
the time it's all in act so what if KJ
made fun of mark at Comic Con it looks
like these two co-stars have a hilarious
love-hate relationship going on behind
the scenes
besides mark is usually the one throwing
shade at KJ a lot of Riverdale fans were
bummed when Jesse broke things off with
Archie because while they're so good
together they were all support and no
dramas so it's nice to know that KJ and
Ashley's bond didn't take a major hit
off screen in fact these buds clearly
have a lot of love and respect for each
other during the same truth-or-dare
segment ashley confirmed what most of us
already knew she and KJ are two peas in
a pod if you had to be stuck on an
island with only one co-star who would
it be
KJ did you see how quickly Ashley
answered that question it's almost as if
she thought of being stranded on an
island with KJ before mmm interesting we
loved their relationship and couldn't
imagine anyone else billing Ashley's
shoes unfortunately the amazing singer
is setting her sights on another
production but more on that later it's
no secret that the Riverdale cast has
had fun on and off the set but that
doesn't mean that they're not working
hard
both Hyrum and RG are tough guys who
have stellar physiques so it makes total
sense that they work out together behind
the scenes some might even say that KJ
and Mark Consuelos have a budding
bromance KJ posted this clip on snapchat
while encouraging mark to keep at it who
would have thought that Archie and
Hiram's were such good pals in real life
hectic filming schedules and public
appearances can take up a lot of time
which is why working actors have little
downtime so it's only normal to want to
catch up on some much-needed rest when
the right moment comes along and thanks
to KJ we now know that mark can fall
asleep pretty much anywhere who knew
being the kingpin of Riverdale could be
so exhausting taking videos of your
friends when they're asleep isn't
exactly a nice thing to do so we're
happy to see Cole Sprouse avenged mark
behind the scenes
judgin Cole scared the
us out of cage a but that's what you get
for filming your co-stars in their most
vulnerable hour unfortunately for the
Riverdale cast it seems like being
filmed while asleep is a trend of some
sorts just look at actor casey kaat who
plays kevin keller taking a
well-deserved nap on the couch but this
time it wasn't KJ who was filming his
co-stars it was Marisol Nichols who
portrays Hermione Lodge on the show the
actress filmed co-stars Casey cot
Vanessa Morgan and machen amick after a
long and exhausting red-eye flight now
that's some risky business but hey
Hermione Lodge is known to take risks
every now and then
as previously mentioned actress Ashley
Marie is leaving Riverdale to reprise
her current role in the upcoming TV
series Katy keen this new TV show will
allow Ashley to showcase her exceptional
singing abilities while taking on a more
essential role it's no secret that
Ashley loves to perform it's what she
was made to do although we're sad to see
her go Josie's talents are wasted on the
little town of Riverdale so we're happy
to hear that she'll be pursuing her
passions on the set of Katy keen the
Riverdale cast is super happy for her
but some co-stars are still in denial
out with the old and in with the new
that's what Ashley is all about it's all
news that the Riverdale cast have formed
unbreakable bonds with each other and we
can't wait to see what they have in
store for us so which one of these
behind-the-scenes moments was your
favorite let us know in the comments
section below and while you're at it
tell us which Riverdale couple is your
all-time favorite we're totally shipping
bug-head and that's the end of our video
for more like this be sure to subscribe
to the things and as usual leave a like
and comment thanks for watching we'll
catch you next time
[Music]